for the a's off the injured list today
right-hander james caprilian
he's five and four with a 3.24 earned
run average
and the batter will be at nathaniel lowe
one or two
there's a swing there's a line shot to
left center field on to run martay he
won't get it
it's in for a base hit it bounds away
from him garcia scores
into second is low and the rangers have
a one-nothing first inning lead
here's andy ibanya as a right-handed
hitter batting 222 with four home runs
the 0-1 pitch now is the ground ball to
the hold it was left up with it a third
is chapman he fires across
for the out post play at first ivanya's
hustles down the line
jordan lyles on the mound the
right-hander five and eight with a 525
earned run average
here recently jordan it didn't pitch so
well as last time out against the angels
canna hitting 251 eleven homer's 37 rbis
for the right-handed battery
two-two pitch breaking ball struck him
out looking one away in the bottom of
the first for the rangers leading one
nothing that'll bring up starling
marte it's buddy
marta can fly how about that how often
do you see a bunt
that goes between the pitcher and the
catcher
and there's no throw made to first base
well it just happened
that's perfect placement so that'll
bring up olson
[Applause]
these are going to take a look at it and
i don't know that marty didn't get his
left hand in there and they call him
safe
so the call is overturned and
gives darling marta a stolen base
out of the stretch at the belt he takes
the runner and now
here's the fish not running and it's
outside olsen walks that'll bring up
lowry
and they as first and second and one out
and jetted 255 with 12 homers and 54
rbis
and now it turns deliverers in jet it's
a drive and a left for a base hit
and martinez around third up with the
ball is martin here's the throw it's
gonna balloon its way into the plate
marte scores lowry lines a base hit to
left
and the azim's hide it up at 1-1 here's
josh harrison
three for nine total in the series it's
that one toward third
hernandez steps on third throws low and
low can't dig it out
should have been a double play it is not
and the inning continues
so here's murphy a right-handed hitter
lyles delivers and murph it's a drive to
left down the line
face hit into the corner scoring as
lowry
harrison around second streaking to
third gets the green light
throw to the plate gonna be close the
slide out at the plate
it looked like harrison was safe it
looked like he got his left hand on the
plate
safe three to one a's
and the a's have a three to one lead
with matt
chapman coming up a runway at third two
balls two strikes two outs
seth brown on deck a lefty pitch to
chapman swing and a miss he got him to
chase a high fastball to end the inning
second strikeout for jordan lyles but
the athletics answer back
they get three runs on three hits
technically no errors but
uh a big miss play and one man left
after one it's three to one open
that'll bring up rock hold here's a 3-2
pitch and swung onto a miss
good fast fall away and holt strikes out
two out
first strikeout for caprilian that'll
bring out the former dodger the center
fielder dj peters
two and two on the way and that's swung
on and miss caprilia strikes out peter
as the inning is over
we go to the bottom of the second it's
three to one athletics
brown strikes out in about a third of
his official plate appearances
the count is two and two lyles pushes
off and lets it fly
and there's a swing in a miss high
fastball got him
brown is retired three punch outs now
for jordan lyles
it's a two out rally and matt olson will
bat with runners at the corners
two balls two strikes two outs runners
at the corners three to one open
second inning runner goes and the pitch
is blasted
deep right field garcia back on the
track he has a play and makes the catch
right up against the wall
olson just got under that one and it
just barely stayed in the ballpark
and lyles escapes the inning no runs two
hits two left
and after two
ready to lead things off here for the
rangers who trail
three to one here's garcia swings and
slams up the middle diving play to his
left by harrison
up and over to first in time what a play
by harrison in the shift
on the left side of second went to his
left left his feet
in the mid up and over and one pitch
retires garcia
to start the fourth inning and here
comes nathaniel lowe has
doubled the other way in the first
setting drove in the lone run so far
for texas nathaniel lowe is only 26
years of age just turned 26 last month
o2 pitch a wave at a miss chase went
outside he's gone on strikes
third k for caprilian and here comes
andy abanez the pitch to a banya as he
swings and lines at the left
right there is cannon back a few strides
reaches up pulls it down an easy one
two three inning for james caprilian uh
to the bottom of the fourth that it is
3-1 oakland
seth brown will start the a's bottom of
the 4th inning they lead it 3-1
3-2 swung on and hit a long way to right
way back
up over and out
for seth brown it's number 13 on the
year
it was gone the moment he made contact
and the a's now lead at four to one
andrews lined out in the second inning
again the two two and this is hit
sharply on the ground to third and
down to his right is hernandez he's got
it comes up
firing and this time in the air gets it
to low just
in time to retire elvis andrews sharply
hit ball that never really came up it
was like a
number 20. just a worm burner there so
the bases are loaded one out and jed
lowry another rbi
opportunity zeroing in on a specific
location now
three balls and a strike four one a's in
the fourth
base is loaded and one out the pitch and
that is
inside ball four he walks in canada it's
5-1 athletics
and jet gets his second rbi today and
number
56 on the year and it brings up josh
harrison
and marty now at third and olson moves
up to second
all right so here's harrison now one for
two and he swings and hits one on the
ground to short is he has a little flip
to abanias for one on to first
double play six four three and that will
limit the damage here
in the fourth inning and that'll bring
up dj peter as he struck out in the
second
two balls and two strikes caprilian at
the belt
turns and delivers and that's taken ring
him up
outside corner fastball perfect pitch
peters knew it
heads back to the dugout two away and
that'll bring up jason martin who's all
for one
holds over third the pitch is a high pop
up playable back at first foul territory
olson's back of the coach's box he's
there and he makes the catch and
caprilian works out of it
and halfway through our ball game today
after four and a half the a's on top of
the ranger is five to one
now matt chapman he has struck out and
hit into a force play
here's the pitch swinging into miss high
fastball
and down goes chapman he is now all for
three today as
hitting woes continue there's yani
hernandez the infield is back except at
third base
the payoff pitch high drive to center
field
medium deep marte over into the alley to
take it
the runner tags and heads home here
comes the throw and scoring standing up
is kind of folefa
so the rangers get back on the board and
they now trail five to two
a sacrifice fly by yanni hernandez
so here's martay three for three and
three singles
the piston starling is a live drive base
hit left center
it's six to two a's scoring is canna
marte turns it first with a single and
that's a four hit game
you can't believe the impact he's made
on this club
and matt chapman is the better chapman
oh for three today he is struck out
twice
2-1 on the way swinging a hard-hit ball
to short and that's caught by connor
falefa
he reached down and kept he caught that
on the backhand side
back to the top of the order for isaiah
kind of falafel here's the swing and
there's a long drive
straight away left that one's way back
and that ball is history
isaiah connor for lefla with his seventh
home run of the year
may narrows the margin to oakland six in
the rangers three
lines smashed by connor falefa
last man for trevino to try to get is dj
peters
and he throws and it's taken ring him up
outside
corner strike three called and the ball
game is over